[Musik]
überraschende Rebellion in Russland der
Chef der Söldnertruppe Wagner Jewgeni
prigoshi startet einen bewaffneten
Aufstand gegen die russische
Militärführung Präsident Putin spricht
von einem Dolchstoß gegen das russische
Volk prigosh ihn selbst behauptet er
wolle Russland retten
und damit guten Abend ihnen allen wir
nutzen die Halbzeitpause um sie auf den
neuesten Stand zu bringen die
wagnertruppe war bislang für Moskau eine
wichtige Stütze im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine jetzt wird sie zur betrogen in
der Nacht drangen Wagner Söldner von der
Ukraine aus auf russischen Boden vor
in Roßdorf am Don haben Sie die
Kontrolle übernommen über das südliche
Hauptquartier der russischen Armee bis
Moskau sind es rund 1.000 km da wollen
sie hin etwa auf halber Strecke bei
Woronesch und in der Region liebt jetzt
wurden Kämpfe gemeldet das erklärte
Ziels in Moskau die oberste
Militärführung absetzen Claudia Weiler
über den Tag in Russland
Panzer einer Privatarmee am Morgen
rollen sie mitten durch Rostow am Don es
sind Wagner seltener die bislang im
Auftrag der russischen Regierung in der
Ukraine gekämpft haben jetzt haben sie
einen neuen Gegner
wir sind im Hauptquartier der russischen
Armee hier in Rostow am London es ist
7:30 Uhr wir haben die militärobjekte
und den Flughafen unter unserer
Kontrolle
Moskau reagiert sofort verhängt den Anti
Terror Alarmzustand sperrt Straßen
verstärkt die Kontrollen kurz danach
eine Fernsehansprache von Präsident
Putin er spricht von Verrätern
das ist ein Dolchstoß für unser Land
unser Volk
diejenigen die einen militärischen
Aufstand vorbereiten haben Russland
verraten und werden dafür bestraft
er sei kein Verräter sondern Patriot
konnte und schickt seine Truppen weiter
Panzer Raketenwerfer und anderes
schweres Gerät am Mittag passieren sie
woronisch auf halbem Weg vom Süden in
die Hauptstadt Moskau offenbar kommt es
zu Kämpfen ein tanklagergerät in Brand
der heutige Vormarsch angeblich auch
Vergeltung für einen tödlichen
Luftangriff russischer Truppen auf
Wagner Soldaten
am Nachmittag dann schickt der Putin
Verbündete tschetschenenführer kadurov
seine Kämpfer Richtung Rostov am Don zum
Kampf gegen die wagnertruppen deren
Panzer nutzen manche heute als Fotomotiv
andere fürchten dass der Machtkampf
eskaliert und dann Russen gegen Russen
kämpfen
fragen wir unsere Russland
Korrespondentin Vögel gab wie weit sind
die wagnerkämpfer noch von Moskau
entfernt wie ist die aktuelle Lage
also die letzten offiziell bestätigten
Meldungen sind eben die dass die Wagner
Söldner im Gebiet lipettes lipettes
Entschuldigung angekommen sind und sich
von dort aus weiter Richtung Moskau
fortbewegen es gibt mehrere Videos in
den sozialen Netzwerken die zeigen
sollen wie Straßen zerstört werden zum
Beispiel mit Baggern vermutlich soll so
versucht werden diesen Vormarsch
Richtung Moskau eben zumindest etwas
abzubremsen der Moskauer Bürgermeister
der hat seine die Bewohner der
Hauptstadt aufgefordert zu Hause zu
bleiben wenn möglich nicht durch die
Stadt zu fahren und er hat den Montag zu
einem arbeitsfreien Tag erklärt ja und
dann gibt es eben immer mehr Videos eben
auch in den sozialen Netzwerken wir
konnten die bisher noch nicht
verifizieren oder unabhängig überprüfen
aber sie scheint zu zeigen dass Ramsan
kadirov mit seinen mit seiner
Privatarmee wiederum in Rostock am Don
angekommen ist und er hatte ja
angekündigt sich der Privatarmee von den
Weg stellen zu wollen wir sprechen
gleich noch mal schauen zuerst noch mal
auf wir gehen die Joachim denn wer ist
dieser Mann der jetzt den Aufstand wagt
ein langjähriger Vertrauter Putins mit
20 wegen Diebstahl und Raub verurteilt
dann die Karriere zum Millionen schweren
Großunternehmer und Söldner Führer
Sebastian ihm hat mir
so zeigt sich hiergeny prigogin am
liebsten in Kampfmontur an der Front nah
dran am Krieg inszeniert sich seit
Monaten als erfolgreicher Kommandeur vor
allem in der Schlacht um bachmut meldete
er sich fast täglich über telegram zu
Wort zuletzt beschimpfte er
Verteidigungsminister Scholl GU
kritisierte fehlende Munition und machte
ihn für den Tod seiner Kämpfer
verantwortlich die Wagner Söldner
spielen in der Ukraine eine wichtige
Rolle in ihren Reihen kämpfen
Ex-Soldaten und rekrutierte Häftlinge
die Truppe ist für ihre Brutalität und
Rücksichtslosigkeit bekannt gegründet
wurde die Gruppe Wagner 2014 sie ist
eine nicht staatliche paramilitärische
Organisation die bisher skrupellos
russische Interessen im Ausland
durchgesetzt hat unter anderem in Syrien
und Mali der Name Wagner soll von
Mitbegründer und Kind stammen die meine
Vorliebe für den deutschen Komponisten
Richard Wagner nachgesagt wird
brigochien galt lange als Vertraute von
Wladimir Putin agierte aber
weitestgehend im Verborgenen doch seit
die seltener in den Ukraine Krieg
eingegriffen haben sind eher und die
Gruppe Wagner der ganzen Welt bekannt
25.000 Mann hören auf meinen Befehl
behauptet
ja wie stark ist diese wagnertruppe
Vögel wie gefährlich kann sie Putin
werden
also in seinem ersten Statement gestern
Abend gesagt er habe 25.000 Menschen
hinter sich ob das stimmt oder nicht sei
mal dahingestellt wie gefährlich er
Putin und dem Machtapparat jetzt werden
kann das hängt ganz mutmaßlich davon ab
wie viele Menschen aus dem
Sicherheitsapparat jetzt womöglich
überlaufen auf seine Seite wechseln und
wie viele wiederum Präsident Putin loyal
bleiben klar ist aber eines ähm hat
Wladimir Putin jetzt schon großen
Schaden zugefügt denn durch diese
Ereignisse seit gestern Nacht steht
Wladimir Putin eben nicht mehr als der
unangreifbare
Kremlherrscher da als der sich so gerne
sehen möchte
danke für diese Einschätzung live aus
Moskau für GABA das
der Krieg gegen die Ukraine geht in
dessen weiter in der Nacht gab es
Luftalarm im ganzen Land 41 russische
Raketen und zwei Drohnen seinen
abgeschossen worden meldet offenbar
wurden in der Hauptstadt aber auch
Gebäude getroffen mindestens drei
Menschen sterben 11 weitere wurden
verletzt auch im ostukrainischen Harke
sollen Raketen eingeschlagen sein
was was bedeutet diese Rebellion in
Russland für den Krieg Alisa jung in
Kiew wie schätzt man das in der Ukraine
ein
mit Sicherheit wird das Auswirkungen auf
den Kriegsverlauf haben wenn auch aus
ministerkolleber gesagt hat das sei
immer noch nicht klar ganz konkret
natürlich welche Auswirkungen das hier
auf die Ukraine hat denn wenn jetzt
natürlich im Russland ein Machtkampf
tobt bedeutet das auch gleichzeitig dass
die wagnertruppe die Putins wichtigste
Kämpfer mit hier waren am an der Front
nicht mehr zur Verfügung stehen die
ukrainische Verteidigungsministerin
hatte sich auch geäußert sprach von
einem Fenster der Möglichkeiten was ich
für die Ukraine auch tun könnte hat
außerdem bestätigt dass die Ukraine
wieder Gelände Gewinne gemacht haben
soll insbesondere im Osten und auch
Präsident selenski hatte sich geäußert
sprach davon dass das Chaos nun so groß
sei das Putin das im eigenen Land nicht
mehr verbergen könnte die Stimmung hier
heute im Kiew ist trotz der
Raketenangriff aus der letzten Nacht
hoffnungsvoll optimistisch denn wo jetzt
natürlich genau hingeschaut wird ist was
bedeutet das für die Logistik für die
Front von den russischen Truppen wenn
jetzt eben der Machtkampf im eigenen
Land tot das Geld ist jetzt in den
nächsten Tagen weiter zu beobachten
hoffnungslos tröstliche Musik auch im
Hintergrund danke für die Informationen
aus Kiew Alissa jung
niemand weiß wie sich das in Russland
entwickelt fragen wir Theo Koll in
Berlin wie bewerten die Bundesregierung
und die westlichen Verbündeten die Lage
also hier wird die Lage als hochexplosiv
eingeschätzt es gab eben im späten
Nachmittag ein Telefonat bei den macron
sunack und Scholz und alle teilten diese
Bewertung und alle wollen sich
zurückhalten damit den Moskau nicht
behauptet werden kann der Westen habe
sich eingemischt habe da irgendwie seine
Finger im Spiel die Warnung des
russischen Außenministeriums in
wagner-aufstand nicht für
russlandfeindliche Ziele zu nutzen die
wird hier sehr ernst genommen anders
die zweite und dritte politische Reihe
in Berlin die die Entwicklung als Chance
für die Ukraine bewertet und das auch
öffentlich macht während des NATO
Mitglied Türkei namlicher Präsident
Erdogan der selbst ja in Putschversuch
erlebt hat Putin heute seine volle
Unterstützung zugesagt hat haben
Lettland und Estland ihre Grenzen zu
Russland nochmals stärker gesichert und
das Auswärtige Amt in Berlin hat die
Reisewarnung für Russland noch einmal
angepasst und auch verschärft danke
schön nach Berlin
das war es von uns wir halten Sie weiter
auf dem Laufenden über die Entwicklung
in Russland mit einem ZDF heute live um
19 Uhr auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
und mit einem heute-journal Spezial hier
nach dem Fußball um viertel nach acht
danke für Ihr Interesse einen schönen
Abend ihnen noch und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend mit diesem hoch genau
über uns und auf der Vorderseite des
mächtigen Atlantik Teams wird es morgen
von Westen noch einmal heiß selbst an
den Küsten gibt es zwischen 23 und 27
Grad sonst 27 bis 33 Grad mit den
höchsten Werten eben an Mosel sah und
Rhein dazu gibt es in der südwest-hälfte
strahlenden Sonnenschein im Nordosten
vormittags mehr Wolken nachmittags
scheint aber auch hier zwischendurch
immer öfter die Sonne und nur ganz
selten tröpfelt es leicht dann wird es
unbeständiger am Montag ist es im Osten
noch einmal heiß bevor uns eine
Kaltfront überquert mit auffrischendem
Wind Regen und Gewittern ab Dienstag ist
nicht mehr ganz so heiß und vor allem im
Norden immer mal wieder nass tschüss